hello guys right right here and i'm
gerry today we're gonna conquer the
galaxy alright galaxy voyage we got sent
this game they said the premise of the
game is to build up your planet mine for
resources produce ships join alliances
and fight others for space domination ok
I'm into space domination I would
dominate an alien anything you're like a
industrial future the a military society
and it's not a pig amazing it's not a
pay to win so this means there's no
[ __ ] here start jump on it Apache oh
alright Oh Christina ran some tests I
ran some tests and found out this planet
is rich in meadow we need to build a
metal minor little so the account i
created if you look in the top left is
the account is reject and a damn i look
hot are you a girl oh yeah oh dude i
paint me oh yeah oh yeah let's take a
look lieutenant I'd like to take a look
in the arrow is pointing at her left
nipple you see that the arrow that's
pointing below below but it wants to
grab it we're never gonna get to the
game if it's Rick tap on the layout plan
to start building a metal nine yes build
for five seconds okay okay our engineers
discovered a way to reduce the
construction line tap free speed up got
it good we are now mining for meadow
will be rewarded after completing
specific tasks yeah I'll give you a
reward Christina dude she's our superior
and she's also ready for Christmas okay
let's see what rewards we got metal is
the key battle mine produces metal
resources and man you have build up your
city gotta build a society and how do
you do that metal structure metal
structures strong sturdy protective hey
you just leveled up like her
big chasm of mine what are we waiting
for let's get to it Wow we need a better
command center we can't we can't command
a city from a dinky command center wow
this game is just really
self-explanatory I'm just upgrading all
the time you gotta build up your society
gets get bigger and bigger and conquest
and what ships can be manufactured in
the shipyard and the new line of
Explorer ships are ready to be built
neato okay see so we're building
ourselves a little society or starting
to get the capability for travel
interstellar travel ship yes whoo use a
quantum hourglass to speed manufacturing
up I want to speed it up because that
that's just not as interesting as I want
it to be I don't care what I'm doing
Jerry dude you're building a society I
know what I'm just lure ships you hadn't
feel like I got a choice on what I'm
doing I feel like I'm just this is all
the setup I mean this is basically
showing you how your command center is
going to work how your ships are gonna
work how to build ships you know where
you can get more resources to build more
buildings you know I'm sure that there's
gonna be like currency and resources you
have to keep track of attack it's all
about building a society the flagship is
the core of the entire fleet it carries
ships in the hangers select your
flagship let's go interplanetary travel
a tack we're gonna verse the sink
Beverly's pirates what do i do how do I
battle oh my that select one of your
ships
take that [ __ ] we've won with one we're
the most fearsome warriors and all the
galaxies galaxies explorations we can
find materials for upgrading ships
resources and experience that's cool
commander our ships were damaged during
the last mission we need to repair them
at the repair shop where where things
get repaired repair shop boom repair
select all repair attack preparation
commander there's an incoming enemy
fleet headed for our planet or let's
[ __ ] these people up let's get ready to
defend no attack whoo-hoo I think we
should fight with honor go to planet
fortification and activate the defense
shields got it dude the best offense is
a good defense we should also deploy
defensively to reduce casualties thanks
for telling me everything I need to know
how to do this makes my life a lot
easier if only we had superiors like you
in real life yeah if somebody would come
along you know when you're cresting into
adulthood and be like this is where
you're gonna work and you're gonna need
to do this and this is where you'll get
your car goddamn it you're about to
enter paddle I'm sorry let heads not in
the game take that man's offense take
that [ __ ] come on weapon is ready
please advise I don't know what I just
did Jerry use the weapon yeah daddy
[ __ ] fire those missile victory
apparently i won explore new planet
claim Wow look at all that [ __ ] I want I
didn't even keep up with that go to the
flagship center
thanks thanks for pointing you know I
like that my boss also highlights what
exactly i'm looking for it's a good boss
right that's a great boss she's making
things very clear and succinct for you
like I don't even get to choose other
things other than what she's highlight
for me which makes my life that much
better well their planet was destroyed
we need allies we need allies I'm
jumping in there's so much to do I want
to join in the Lions really I'm joining
the Canadian one try that corporation o
Christmas pack I like that we celebrate
Christmas things in this realm Wow
Christmas package that's everything I've
ever wanted for Christmas like a quantum
hourglass all right I oh now I get to
choose what I want to do yeah dude oh
here we go yeah Jerry what should we
choose first dude maybe we should up our
eyes our command center or maybe our
repair station ok ihan we need to
prepare defenses way no I gotta prepare
my good good good you're you are rising
good you're like maverick and Top Gun
explore a galaxy 5 times complete five
daily quests ok wow there's a lot of
to-do lists here I'm gonna do this job
requires a lot it's not like doing
reactions yeah dude it's about strategy
it's about figuring out what would make
the most effective society alright we're
building a crystal mine right now oh
good Oh like Superman's layer
construction complete perfect perfect we
use that for currency or Oh up with the
crystalline the crystal mine will
protect you from the aliens [ __ ] all
over your face I don't think that's in
the program it's exactly the same
sixty-nine percent 100% construction is
complete oh sweet you can zoom in on
these guys a little [ __ ] planet
fortification let's upgrade this [ __ ]
yeah dude wow this this camp is ready to
be under attack
no we're ready for anything okay so this
game is kind of cool it's like you're
running your own planet and it is one of
those like building games you get to
author your own experience to create
your own society the way you would run
and then you theoretically find out if
you're a crappy leader or a good leader
I dude I'm just building and building
and building and I feel like I can't
you're unstoppable I feel like I can't
do this yes you can Ryan you're a leader
I am me to us we're exploring galaxies
and I'm going to attack yes honk West
that's how I attack I'm sending cheetah
after these guys she did Mellark
fire fire fire it will fire destroy them
conquer their planet wow I'm telling you
I got the best troops ever there you can
leave the Galactic Empire at this rate
Zach huh such it I like that you
attacked with such gustav electronic
projection art take that whoa as a giant
missile did no we want dude you're a
victoire feel like we don't even get to
finish the battle amen that's how good
you are is is so quick on I'm just
attacking all these planets right now it
honestly feels really good I mean I
think power is starting to corrupt you
[ __ ] you Jerry you're not my friend I
don't know you I don't know you do if I
just destroy all these plan who go to
that fiery one in the middle no man you
gotta go in order see this is why you're
a better there's my way better leader
than you [ __ ] thanks to vodacom yeah
it's called empowerment
so how I'm gonna [ __ ] these guys up
really take that take that claiming my
prize really one day these games will
build in a strap-on I don't think that's
gonna help you in space haha I am
powerful with these huge breasts I have
build your defenses people we must
prepare to attack because that is what
we do best here they got a Christmas
tree here oh they're Christians their
Christian my town is too what's not my
town my planet but your Christianity is
different from my Christianity we must
destroy you know you will never destroy
space Jerry no not space jerry and i
knows you you can't be space Jerry I'm
totally spaced yeah there's like a city
like this is like looking at concept art
like it's in a good way yeah it's pretty
cool anyway guys we just wanted to
introduce you see that game galaxy
voyage cuz I have an account there so
you guys can find me I'm under reject I
am space Jerry space Jerry so don't uh
don't forget to follow us here
construction is complete on my flagship
yeah don't forget yeah if you if you
want to play hit us up we will get we
will get intergalactic also creators of
the game if you're able these are based
off like real life models I'd like to
meet them
I like to meet them look at me yeah
you're all you can change your I don't
want to change it like I'm gonna check
out man you can change your nationality
I'm gonna go by space Ryan that space
right if the avatars look like her that
would have been a much better movie and
sam worthington katha done a great job
in that role